many apps work with large sets of data
but only need to load and display a
small portion at any given time if
you're not careful you might request
data you don't actually need wasting
your users battery and bandwidth if the
data you're displaying is constantly
updating it can be difficult to keep
your UI in sync and still send only a
small amount of information over the
network the paging library part of just
packed tackles these problems enabling
you to load data gradually and
gracefully the library supports both
large but bounded lists as well as lists
of unbounded sites such as continuously
updating feeds it offers integration
with recyclerview which is typically
used to display large data sets and
place nicely with either live data or rx
Java for observing new data in your UI
the painting library is based on the
idea of sending lists to the UI with a
live data of a list that is observed by
the recyclerview adapter it then builds
up on this idea by adding paging so you
can load content gradually let's go over
the main components of the library and
see how they fit in your apps
architecture the core elements in the
paging library are the page list and the
data source a page list is a collection
that loads data in chunks known as pages
asynchronously a data source is the base
class for loading snapshots of data into
a given page list data sources can be
backed by the network database file orb
anywhere you want to retrieve data from
you create a data source using a data
source Factory object the paging library
also provides a page list adapter which
helps you present data from page lists
in a recycler view the pages adapter is
notified when pages are loaded and it
uses the few tail to compute fine-grain
updates as new data is received the
paging library provides the live page
list builder class for getting a live
data object of type page list to create
a live pages builder pass in the data
source Factory object and a paging
configuration if you prefer working with
our Java instead of live data then just
use the
page two this builder it's constructed
similarly to life page list builder but
instead of a live data object it will
return an observable or flowable
depending on what you need let's take a
look at some common scenarios uploading
data from a database or a retrofit based
network source and see how the paging
library helps so first case let's say
that the database is your data source
the room persistence library provides
native support for paging library data
sources for a given query room allows
you to return any data source factory
from the doll and handles the
implementation of the data source for
you second case let's say that the
database is a cache for data loaded from
network so here you would still return a
data source factory from the DAO but you
would also need to implement another
paging component a boundary call back
the battery callback loads more data
when the user gets near the end of the
data that's in the local cache after the
data is asserted the paging library
automatically updates the UI but don't
forget to associate the boundary call
back with a live page this builder you
created earlier that way it can be used
by the page list third case having only
the network as your data source here you
will have to create both your data
source and your data source factory but
when choosing which data source type to
extend consider what your back-end API
looks like if you need to request data
from your back-end based on a key you
will extend from item keyed data source
let's take an example you might need to
get the first 100 commits added to a
github repository after a certain date
then the date will be the key for your
data source item kids data source allows
you to define how to load the initial
page as well as how to load items both
after and before a kid entry if you're
back and expose is api's that work with
pages then you will extend from page key
to data source for example the search
repositories github API returns
paginated items in the github API
request you need to specify the query
which page you want and optionally the
number of items per page
independent on how you create your
network data source you will need to
implement a data source factory that
knows how to create your data source for
full examples of how to implement all of
these cases including how to handle
error cases or return mechanisms check
out our samples on github okay let's sum
it up here's what you'll need to do to
integrate paging you'll need to define
your data source create a boundary call
back if it's needed create the live data
of a page this with the help of a live
page list filter update your adapter to
be a page this adapter and then finally
observe the live data of a page list in
your UI and set the page list to the
adapter that's it just five steps check
out our documentation code samples and
call up and start using the paging
library to provide smooth performing
lists for your users
[Applause]